winona ryder is reflecting on her past
relationship with ex-fiance johnny depp
i've been married for years you can't
tell anybody
and how difficult it was after they
split the actress covers harper's
bazaar's july digital issue and in her
interview with the mag she talks about
the hard times she had after she and
johnny ended their engagement in the
early 90s you'll recall the two began
dating in 1989 and got engaged just five
months after their first date and
there's no forgetting the couple
co-starred in the 1990 hit edward
scissorhands
are you okay
yes are you okay
but i think this one really does have
the romance and the fairy tale and it's
a thriller and it's uh
you know it has it has everything
it's a great combo platter
sort of a mixed bag but the pair split
in 1993 and winona tells harper's bazaar
the breakup and 90s tabloid culture at
the time was her girl interrupted real
life of course she's referring to the
1999 film she starred in about a young
woman in a psychiatric hospital achieve
mental health and my discharge sheet
reads
recover
recover
then winona recalls her role in the 1993
film the house of spirits where she
plays a girl who gets tortured in a
chilean prison anne describes how she
took the advice of her therapist and
tried to imagine being gentle to her
younger self i would look at these fake
bruises and cuts on my face from the
chute and i would struggle to see myself
as this little girl would you be
treating this girl like you're treating
yourself i remember looking at myself
and saying this is what i'm doing to
myself inside because i just wasn't
taking care of myself but winona says
during her struggles she had support
from her age of innocence co-star
michelle pfeiffer she says i remember
michelle being like this is going to
pass but i couldn't hear it and that
close bond with the actress is something
winona talked about with e.t in the
early 90s michelle was like great
girlfriend for me to have i mean we
would like bead you know necklaces and
like you know she was really like fun to
hang out with and
and
we didn't have a lot of scenes together
but we were
for some reason we were always around on
the same days and
she was great and
really you know kind of
sisterly to me fast forward decades
later and winona is pretty private about
her romances over the years the actress
has been dating scott mcinley han for
more than a decade and she tells the mag
it's something she really did try to
keep quiet about we have so much in
common we connected on so many levels
but it was amazing that he's not in the
business
[Music]